hello and welcome to this video
I shouldn't have requested this game is
this sound outside makes me crazy
but ok let's play it now I am absolutely
sensitive to those dumb noises yeah I
think this is how they play it nowadays
[Music]
drama doll that Jasper Hall I'm not
looking it up again
I will go g5 at some point and do stuff
on the kingside and Queen d2 is actually
running right into this with Bishop h6
so Queen h4 yeah let's go there really a
funky position yeah it's really funny
it's very unusual position g3 what
you're giving me that's you cannot be
serious here
what is he doing here
it looks like absolutely suicidal okay
so I'm taking this and now okay he's got
Queen f1 just about Queen f1 okay I go
here
and fortunately I cannot SEC the Queen
yet suit close but this is good this is
good yeah
maybe to age six 92f form but okay 92 I
have bishop basics
ah crazy that sound
yeah I should have gone to h6 don't give
them the temple
not sure how much it matters though
[Music]
I take on f3 Nexus queen h1
as tegus you cannot take one of three
now
check
what a strange am white resides dad
seems he completely ignored everything
that I was doing there somehow I mean
this is a very very valid idea here to
play h4 is actually wrong right I mean I
go g5 anyway and he opens up the H file
for me so the black idea is g5 and he
just makes it worse by allowing all that
yeah this is already very comfortable
for black you know the engine evaluation
is actually pretty conservative I mean I
was thinking this is really a lot better
already
maybe the engine needs a bit of time to
see how bad the H file will become
really really bad position for white but
gg3 is just I don't know what to say I
mean why do you give me the light
squares you know with with white I don't
know yeah this is this is losing but I
was I was sloppy again yeah in this
position Queen h6 is better than Queen
h5 it's it's just a bit easier now here
if I go this he can still play this move
and it's not entirely clear and if I'm
instead go to age 60 M then against 92
okay King g7 seems to be even better but
this is also very strong move activating
the last piece that didn't do anything
at King g7 rook h8 is just an automatic
win
yeah so I lost the tempo they have it
just it just it's just just a terrible
position yeah I mean that was extremely
cooperative the black ideas is g5 anyway
and with this he just opens up the H
file from my own play that's really
really friendly okay guys thanks for
watching